and we're back in atlanta here site of
super bowl 53 joining us now a guy who
won the 2018 heisman trophy as the best
player in all of college football he'll
he may be a pro baseball player maybe a
pro football player but feeling that may
come up over the next few minutes he's
kyler murray kyler great to see you
thanks for having me hey congratulations
man what a career you've had in college
football did when you decided to play
last season what was winning the heisman
trophy was that on your own personal
list of achievements
um i'll be lying to you if i said no
something i've always dreamed of as a
little kid you know growing up
watching the game of college football on
tv my dad played football you know
played multiple sports but you know just
knowing his background
it was definitely something i always
wanted to do for sure where do you keep
the heisman
all right
i sleep right next to it
right right on the red stand it's right
there or is it in the bed itself
no it's uh okay no it's not in the bed
itself it's it's right right on the
nightstand for sure what what was your
dad best at sports-wise
football
i heard he was pretty good at basketball
as well
so um
what do you think of this experience i
know this is the first for you to come
to something like this make the rounds
talk to people what's been your reaction
so far
well i'm just you know i'm out here with
missing maine obviously they've uh you
know they invited me out here so it's
you know me and my family out here for
the first time out of super bowl uh i
always watch them on tv uh
my first day out here is not that hectic
yet but i know it's gonna get pretty
hectic uh so i'm just you know i'm just
glad i'm here you know just having fun
with it you know i saw some of the
things you said after the semifinal loss
to alabama and i thought maybe just
maybe i know gill brandt the the great
longtime cowboy scout believe this that
you were going to come back to oklahoma
for one more year did you give that any
serious consideration yeah no i don't
know
i don't know where anybody was getting
that at uh it was either you know it was
for sure you know play play another
season
and then um go play baseball that was
the whole you know the thing so
um and now the decision obviously more
complicated because of the success you
had last year yes sir
now and i know that you've said
previously today that that you're not
ready to make a commitment that's fine
you take your time you make a commitment
when you're ready have you given any
thought to
making your commitment based upon where
you're drafted based upon which team
drafts you based upon how high your
draft basically hey if i get to go where
i want to go i'll play football
otherwise i'll play baseball
well see i don't think it's that easy um
i mean the a's organization has been
nothing you know but
phenomenal to me uh throughout this
whole process uh you know i i wouldn't
want to be with anybody else because i
mean they've
the way they've handled this whole
situation has been crazy you know
almost you know you wouldn't believe it
but um
i don't think you can i feel like
everybody would do this if it was you
know let me see where i get drafted and
then
uh
if i go if i go later then then yeah
i'll come play you know i'm saying i
don't
i don't know if that's possible but you
know when you when you rave about the
aids organization it makes me think
maybe there is something to be said for
seeing which organization in the nfl
drafts you because maybe it's a good
organization like the a's maybe it's not
a good organization do you want to slam
the door on playing for the a's before
you're drafted by an nfl team is that
part of your thought process
uh me personally
me personally i'm just
trying to tell you one day at a time uh
this you know this whole decision thing
it's uh
i wish i could play both i i you know
that's just me personally obviously i
know it's you know
highly highly highly unlikely but um
you know
it's it's not an easy decision i've been
playing both my whole life uh since i
was four years old so
um you know well i gotta make a decision
obviously but uh
yeah i'm not gonna i'm not standing up
here so what's what's your timetable for
making it really soon
have you already made it and you just
aren't ready to announce it
and you have every right to not announce
it i just get the feeling you've already
made your decision uh
honestly i mean i wouldn't say that
i get the impression that if you really
had your way you would try to play both
of course
do you do you think that you said highly
highly highly unlikely that's different
from saying it's impossible are you
holding out hope that maybe there's a
way the dominoes fall that you could at
least try to play both
i i i heard something about russell
wilson uh you know he was speaking about
you know my situation and he's been
through it uh i heard him say you know
if
he'd have to be in uh
or new york or because he's he's with
the yankees so he'd have to be you know
on the giants or the jets or something
like that so
um
him saying that he knows the he knows
the schedule
as far as you know being a you know
successful quarterback in the league uh
so i i don't i don't think so unless i
was
picked by the raiders but
when you sit down and they're not going
to be in oklahoma much longer
yeah if that was the case yeah i'd have
to be in oakland a and
a raider but
when you sit down and think about the
pros and cons and we had russell wilson
here earlier and he talked about the
pros and cons baseball and football what
give me one pro
for each sport one if you're listing the
good things what would you list one for
each sport
oh
[Music]
and there's a lot uh you know i've
weighed out all the options kind of
really my family
you know
baseball everybody says you know the
longevity
uh the money
i think either way man the pros to it
are just the fact that
i love to play the game and uh
at the end of the day i'd be doing what
what makes me happy
what about from the football side same
thing
do you worry more about health risks of
football than baseball
uh
you can't play that way i mean you can't
you can't go into it thinking you know
wow what if i get hurt uh
i feel like that'll just hold you back
and for me for me personally i know it
you know the nfl is a different beast
but i if you've watched me play before
if you know me you know i try to stay as
safe as possible obviously i'm not the
biggest stature you know but
you know hits are inevitable
in the league they are i mean they're
inevitable in high school they're
inevitable in college i've taken hits
before obviously there's there's bigger
guys in the league uh faster guys in the
league but
uh
i i for me i just go out there and try
to play my game and you know
not get hit as much as possible that's
for sure baker mayfield was trying to
call you a couple times while we were
setting up and
uh i i love baker mayfield and i love
what he brings to the table i love his
attitude i love his moxie i love his
skills i love that he just is determined
to go out and be the best player he can
be all the time and he lifts those
around him what kind of advice has he
given you in this process
uh you know he he's uh
i don't think you know i've said this a
lot you know i don't think you know if i
hadn't sat behind him uh for the those
two years
that i would have you know
i've always had i'm a very confident
self-motivated guy obviously but you
know just the success that i did have in
oklahoma you know i give a lot of credit
to him and just watching him you know
do it on that level you know i did in
high school but you know i think you
know watching him you know kind of show
me how to how to go about things and do
stuff
on the field and you know in the in the
maybe not so much off the field but uh
he's he's just been a great great friend
of me a great dude to me and you know
we're both from texas but throughout
this whole process i've talked to him a
lot you know as far as even when the
heisman the heisman and so forth so it's
it's uh he's been good to me is he
trying to push you to play football of
course
and and you have to be tempted right
when you see what he's done and the
impact he's had right away and already
one of the best quarterbacks in the nfl
does that make you say man
i really want to go out there and do
what baker's doing
uh as far as like the nfl yeah well
he's calling again
no i uh
well i'll say as far as the heisman deal
uh you know seeing him win a heisman
i've always wanted to win a heisman
obviously but i think you know i was
determined to go back to back and um
i think that just kind of you know takes
whatever you know as far as football
goes me seeing him play play well in the
nfl level i know i knew he was going to
do what he's going to do
you know with everybody doubting and
stuff but for me i mean i'm a different
guy
i love to see him succeed and yes if i
played football yes i would love to go
succeed but if i play baseball then i'm
going to want to go succeed that way too
so i mean before i let you go and i
appreciate you taking time for us today
i know you lot have a lot going on tell
us what you have about uh going on with
ms and him name no doubt um
dallas based company um you know my
hometown so it's right up the street um
you know kind of linked up with them you
know it's really uh
i hope i look good you look good yeah
you look good i hope i look good
it's
really comfortable it's really you know
fit for athletic guys you know athletic
bodies uh keeps you cool um
i've been sweating earlier and you can't
even tell i've been sweating so um i
mean i'm just
i'm happy i look good i'm happy you know
they invited me out here to my first
super bowl event so so um it's a real
neat deal and i got something for you so
all right i'll check it out that's good
i appreciate it well we we congratulate
you on all your success and whatever
decision you make look you make the
decision you move on you don't look back
and you go be the best you can be
whatever you choose and who knows maybe
you play both then wouldn't that be a
story if that happens kyler murray
heisman trophy winner future pro
baseball player or pro football player
or who knows maybe both we'll be back
with more from atlanta
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports